es ist eine heikle Frage wie viel
Aufnahmefähigkeit kann sich Deutschland
leisten eine Obergrenze dürfen nicht
sein sagen die einen ein Sozialstaat
ohne Abweisung sei illusorisch sagen die
anderen das kann nicht zusammen
funktionieren es ist ein Dilemma das
nicht
aus die Frage ob wir die reinlassen oder
nicht sondern schaffen wir eine
nachhaltige Integration es ist ein Thema
das moralisch vermiet ist über das
manche besonders gern andere auch
deswegen lieber gar nicht mehr sprechen
ich glaube dass ein Tabu Schaden
anrichtet das war jetzt die Folge das
ist eine Schweigespirale gibt ne dass
keiner richtig drüber jedenfalls die
demokratischen Parteien ungern darüber
reden wir haben geredet mit dreien die
das politische Geschäft seit Jahrzehnten
kennen nun aber raus sind und daher noch
offene reden können als früher mit
Wolfgang Schäuble CDU
Marie-Luise Beck von den Grünen
und sieht man Gabriel SPD
es ging um emotional aufgeladene Fragen
ich glaube es ist fast unmöglich da die
Emotionen herauszubekommen
beides nicht geschafft wir haben
sozusagen die Zuwanderung nicht
kontrolliert aber sie darf nicht
besonders gut in der Integration die
Menschen müssen das Vertrauen haben dass
dieser Staat die Dinge kontrollieren
kann
Rückblick 2015 damals fiel dieser eine
so polarisierende Satz nach Tagen solche
bis dahin ungekannter Bilder wenn wir
jetzt anfangen uns noch entschuldigen zu
müssen dafür dass wir in Notsituationen
einen freundliches Gesicht zeigen dann
ist das nicht mein Land 2015 war
insofern der Sondersituation als wir von
unserem Nachbarland Österreich
sozusagen den Anruf kriegen da kommen
ganz viele Leute ihr müsst uns helfen
wir sind ein kleines Land wir sind acht
Millionen ihr seid 80 Millionen wir
können uns nicht im Regen stehen lassen
und damals haben gesagt na klar okay wir
machen das ich bin dann übrigens nach
Jordanien geflogen und eines dieser
Flüchtlingslager um mal zu fragen warum
kommt es eigentlich jetzt auf einmal zu
der Welle es gab von allen Leitern der
flüchtlingsorganisation die gleiche
Antwort seit das Geld nicht mehr
ausreicht der UN
um das Welt Ernährungsprogramm zu
finanzieren und Schulen und
Krankenhäuser zu finanzieren und seit
die Hoffnung nicht mehr da war nach
Syrien zurückzukommen ist der Strom nach
Deutschland losgegangen er warnte wenig
später für eine Lawine eine Wortwahl die
ihm viel Kritiker brachte
ich hatte einfach nur recht es tut mir
furchtbar leid das ist eben so mit der
Entscheidung
10.000 oder 20.000 Flüchtlinge von
Budapester Bahnhof in Deutschland
aufzunehmen ist die Botschaft entstanden
Germany ist Open die hat sich innerhalb
von Minuten in der ganzen Welt
verbreitet es geht heute mit den
modernen mit den modernen Kommunikations
Kanäle ganz rasend schnell und weil das
nicht gelungen ist muss heute die
Botschaft sein wir entscheiden selber
wer auf Dauer nach Europa nach
Deutschland kommen kann und wenn wir in
Europa der offenen Grenzen erhalten
wollt dann müssen wir das gemeinsam an
den Außengrenzen exekutieren
das nicht auflösbar ist selbst wenn wir
uns als Europa zusammentun würden was ja
nicht gelingt bisher wäre es eine
unglaubliche Herausforderung wir haben
mit dem Ukraine krieg jetzt
Displays persons 8 Billionen es gibt
höhere Schätzungen
Syrien ist ja kein Gebiet wo der Krieg
aufgehört hat von der armuts und Hunger
und auch
wasserknappheits Migration aus Afrika
ganz zu schweigen es sind
Größenordnungen
die
sich nicht einfach hineinfügen lassen in
unsere Gemeinwesen eine Erkenntnis die
damals recht schnell auch ihr Handeln
bestimmte das freundliche Gesicht sah
bald schon so aus zumindest war jene die
über die Türkei nach Europa wollten
Erdogan als Türsteher und Grenzzäune
nicht freundlich aber effektiv die Zahl
illegaler einreisen ging rapide runter
nun aber geht sie wieder hoch seit
längerem schon und aktuell so stark wie
seit sieben Jahren nicht mehr
die meisten Asylanträge EU-weit werden
in Deutschland gestellt mit einigem
Abstand
[Musik]
da braucht er nur durch die Städte gehen
um zu mit sozusagen jeden Tag zu sehen
das ist uns nicht gelingt eine so große
Anzahl jedes Jahr nachhaltig zu
integrieren das ist ja nicht die Frage
ob wir die reinlassen oder nicht sondern
schaffen wir eine nachhaltige
Integration die von Haus Seehofer mal
debattierte Obergrenze finde ich muss
ich orientieren an der Frage wie viele
Menschen bekommen wir in Bildung in
Wohnung in Arbeit und da glaube ich sind
wir nah an der Überforderung in
Deutschland sind die Sozialleistungen
deutlich höher als in vielen anderen
Ländern das wirke als pullfaktor sagen
Migrationsforscher also Leistungen
kürzen
das hat ja immer mal wieder
abschreckungsmodelle gegeben also im
Grunde genommen ein Szenario
zusammenzubauen wo das Leben so
unerträglich ist dass die Menschen gar
nicht erst kommen ich habe als ich noch
Ausländer beauftragte war solche Orte
besucht es ist grauenhaft die Menschen
dort hatten Zimmer mit Stockbetten
mehrere Betten in einem Raum
keine Möglichkeit zu kochen also keine
Betätigung ich meine das so etwas so
eine Härte eine Gesellschaft sich nicht
leisten darf wenn wir den Menschen von
denen nicht feststeht dass sie auf Dauer
hier bleiben können höhere soziale
Leistungen anbieten als andere
europäische Länder brauchen wir uns
nicht darüber zu beklagen dass in einem
Europa offener Grenzen die Menschen nach
am liebsten alle nach Deutschland kommen
die Menschen sind nicht blöd und
deswegen brauchen wir in einem Europa
der offenen Grenzen ein gemeinsames Maß
an Sozialleistungen für diejenigen von
denen ich verstehe dass sie dauernd hier
bleiben können deutschland ist für viele
Menschen der Jackpot den man in Europa
finden kann nicht nur wegen der
Sozialsysteme auch weil es Menschen der
gibt die aus der eigenen Kultur kommen
weil es ein Land gibt mit unglaublich
vielen Arbeitsmöglichkeiten ein großes
Land ist und ein wirtschaftlich sehr
erfolgreich ist
die sozialfaktoren dass man bei uns eine
vernünftige soziale Absicherung hat ist
gehört dazu aber ich habe Zweifel daran
dass das Kürzen der Sozialleistung dazu
führt das weniger kommen das Land bleibt
ein Sehnsuchtsort es ist ja auch erstmal
ein Zeichen der ja wie soll man sagen
ist erstmal etwas worauf die Deutschen
ja auch stolz sein können dass das ein
Sehnsuchtsort geworden ist aber der hat
eben auch die Kehrseite dass wir nicht
für alle diesen Sehnsuchtsort eröffnen
können weil es uns überfordert die
zuständige Ministerin hat viel
angekündigt zuletzt verschärfte
abschieberegeln etwa und die Einigung in
Brüssel im Juni zu mehr europäischer
Zusammenarbeit nannte sie historisch an
Deutschlands Grenzen hat er das bislang
wenig geändert vor allem in Sachsen und
Brandenburg gelangen viele Menschen
illegal ins Land
stationäre Grenzkontrollen lehnt Faser
dennoch nach wie vor ab weshalb die
Polizei niemanden zurückweisen darf
die Menschen müssen das Vertrauen haben
dass dieser Staat die Dinge
kontrollieren kann und wenn das der
Staat nicht mehr den Menschen vermittelt
dann darf man sich nicht wundern wenn
das Vertrauen in den freiheitlichen
demokratischen Rechtsstaat und seine
Institution abnimmt und dass das sind
Gegnern der freiheitlich
rechtsstaatlichen parlamentarischen
Demokratie nützen wir erleben das
Erstarken einer Partei die im
Wesentlichen mit einem Thema
sich stark macht nämlich zu sagen
schließt schließt uns ab wir wollen
keine Einwanderung und
man kann das versuchen wegzuschweigen
man kann aber in einer Demokratie
die Menschen nicht dazu zwingen ihr
Wahlkreuz bei solchen Parteien nicht zu
machen also insofern gibt es keine
Alternative als diese Auseinandersetzung
und dieses Gespräch zu führen was wir
eigentlich brauchen ist dass das
demokratische Zentrum dieses Landes sich
dieser Frage widmet und zwar nach
Möglichkeit ohne Streit ohne Wahlkampf
und dabei gleichzeitig der Bevölkerung
reinen Wein einschenkt und sagt es wird
keine bilderbuchlösungen geben ich habe
auch in der flüchtlingskrise zur 15
erlebt dass es zwei Teile von Politik
gibt
den Bundestag der sozusagen auch die
richtige Motivation hatte zu helfen und
das sollte mit ganz wenigen Ausnahmen
und die Kommunen die vorher gesagt haben
Vorsicht Vorsicht Vorsicht wir schaffen
das alles nicht so ganz einfach
wer tatsächlich vor politischer
Verfolgung fliehe oder für Krieg dem
solle weiter ohne Abstriche geholfen
werden auch wegen unserer Geschichte
betont sie gleich wohl wir haben eine
dritte Gruppe die kommt auch und ich
finde das sollte man nicht verschweigen
weil sie ein besseres Leben sucht das
ist eine finde ich gerechte Lösung
anzuerkennen dass wir als wohlhabende
Industrienation
auch diese Chance auf ein besseres Leben
mit in unserer Aufnahmebereitschaft
hineinnehmen das aber dann in einer Zahl
die tatsächlich politisch festgelegt
wird
die Regeln des 20 Jahrhunderts das
Individualrecht auf Asyl und die Genfer
Flüchtlingskonvention auch im 21
Jahrhundert noch passen diese
grundsätzliche Frage war jüngst er auf
das surecht in der deutschen Verfassung
ist
entstanden in dem Blick zurück auf die
Zeit des Nationalsozialismus und die
politische verhung in Europa und ist
deshalb auch zurecht als Individualrecht
ausgestaltet worden das heißt jeder
einzelne Fall muss geprüft worden werden
und es ging um politische Verfolgung der
Begriffe ist dann ein bisschen erweitert
worden auch um andere Arten der
Verfolgung und werden es heute zu tun
doch mit relativ großen
Wanderungsbewegungen die nicht nur
politische Verfolgung zum Hintergrund
haben und auch nicht nur Krieg dafür
gäbe es ja auch den Genfer
Flüchtlingskonvention sondern in großem
Maße auch armutswanderung ich persönlich
kann nicht sagen dass ich finde das
politische Verfolgung ein höheren
Stellenwert haben soll als wenn eine
Mutter für ihre Kinder
irgendwie ein besseres Leben haben will
die Zahlen sind eben so groß geworden
dass wir mit dem Individualrecht glaube
ich nicht viel Weiterkommen sondern wir
werden andere
pragmatischere Umgangsform finden müssen
eine solche pragmatische Lösung die
derzeit von migrationsforschern
diskutiert wird vom una CR durchgeführte
Asylverfahren in afrikanischen
Drittstaaten wie Senegal oder Ruanda
auch um gefährliche Überfahrten künftig
vorab zu verhindern
wenn sich Menschen in einem Boot setzen
dann sterben viele und das erleben wir
jetzt wieder im zentralen Mittelmeer um
sie davon abzuhalten ohne ihre
Menschenrechte zu verletzen und ohne
dass Asylrecht aufzugeben brauchen wir
Partnerländer und der beste Weg das zu
tun ist wir retten Menschen und bringen
sie dann in Staaten die tatsächlich
sicher sind wo dann Asylverfahren die
glaubwürdig sind stattfinden können und
das ist nicht die Widerspruch zur
flüchtlings- oder
Menschenrechtskonvention das rettet
Leben aber es ist Arbeit denn diese
Länder müssen ein Interesse haben hier
mit uns zu kooperieren aber daran müsste
die Bundesregierung und europäische
Demokratien jetzt arbeiten zentral sei
dabei dass humanitäre rechtsstaatliche
Voraussetzungen erfüllt sind
wir haben auch bereits erfolgreiche
Verhandlungen die etwa Großbritannien
mit Ruanda geführt hat ruanda ist bereit
Leute aufzunehmen und wir haben eine
Gerichtsentscheidung von Ende Juli aus
London die klar sagt
Menschen für etwas Asylverfahren in
einen Staat wir waren dazu bringen ist
im Einklang mit der
Menschenrechtskonvention solange dort
faire Asylverfahren stattfinden das
Gericht hat auch gesagt die sind noch
nicht fair aber daran kann man arbeiten
und wenn der Ohrenarzt er sie machen
würde zum Beispiel dann wäre das eine
Lösung ein Weg aus dieser Krise genug zu
tun wäre also für die Ampel die aber
wird auffällig des interessiert einem
Gipfel im Mai folgte wenig und auch da
ging es weniger ums grundsätzliche
sondern vor allem darum wer die Kosten
übernimmt und oder Länder
natürlich ist es auch eine Frage wer
bezahlt was Bund Länder und gemein es
geht immer ich war acht Jahre lang
Finanzminister der Streit wer welche
staatliche Ebene welche Anteil am am
öffentlichen an steueraufgabe der
öffentlichen Haushalt hat ist auch ein
Streit glauben Sie das interessiert die
Menschen das interessiert die
Flüchtlinge nicht es interessiert eben
übrigens auch die Menschen in
Deutschland nicht weil sie sagen macht
es löst das Problem ich glaube nicht
dass man die Chance hat eine Antwort zu
finden die alle in dieser Gesellschaft
zufrieden stellt
aber
wir müssen die Auseinandersetzung führen
und ich glaube dass doch die Chance
besteht dass die Mehrheit unserer
Gesellschaft
diese Form von Menschlichkeit auch als
Lehrer aus der deutschen Geschichte nach
wie vor in Deutschland hochhält
natürlich haben wir eine historische
Verantwortung aber ich würde sagen jeder
andere Europäer der im Gedanken der
Aufklärung groß geworden ist der was
sozusagen von Menschenrechten von
Humanität hält der hat ja keine andere
Verantwortung dafür als die Deutschen
die Tatsache dass wir unglaubliche
Verbrechen in der Vergangenheit aus
diesem Land heraus im kennen dafür nicht
dazu führen dass wir deshalb uns dieser
Debatte nicht stellen wir
was was soll das dann für ein Ergebnis
haben wenn wir als Land in dem der
größte Zahl der Menschen für Heimat zu
finden wenn wir darüber nicht sprechen
im übrigen hat der Bundespräsident der
frühere bundespräsident Gauck den
schönsten Satz formuliert den will ich
immer einfach nicht wegnehmen
unser herzlich groß aber unsere
Möglichkeiten sind begrenzt und das muss
man sagen
das verstehen viele in der derzeitigen
Koalition wollen es nicht verstehen das
ist für viele gerade bei den Grünen auch
für Frau Beckham übrigens natürlich ein
Herzen seinen legen das verstehe ich
aber Politik heißt um mit Nathan dem
weißen also Lessing zu reden
der sagt er zu seiner Tochter begreifst
du wie viel leichter andächtig schwärmen
als gut handeln lässt regieren heißt gut
handeln aber sie leben immer in
perfekten man wird schuldig man kann die
Dinge nicht perfekt lösen aber das was
man machen kann muss man tun